(loud whoosh)
(bang)
- What's up, Believe Nation?
So in January, I got really sick
and made it a goal for myself
to never get sick again,
to always be healthy,
and a key part of that
was going to be studying
the methods of Wim Hof,
applying it to my life,
and seeing if it worked.
We made our first video.
It did really well.
A lot of you guys were asking,
feedback in the comments
afterwards, "Does this really work?
"What was the impact?"
And so today we're going to follow along
investigative journalist and
author of What Doesn't Kill Us,
Scott Carney, as he investigates,
does the Wim Hof method actually work?
(techno music)
(inspirational music)
- I traveled to Poland
to expose a charlatan,
a prophet who claimed he could give
ordinary people superpowers.
He said he could control his
body temperature at will,
hijack his immune system,
and conquer the world's tallest mountains
with no cold weather gear.
I'd built my career as an
investigative journalist
debunking people like him.
But to prove he was a liar or a madman,
I had to try his method.
I'm not an athlete, I'm not exceptional,
but I found a power that
I never knew humans had.
I hiked to the summit of Mount
Kilimanjaro without a shirt.
I sat on the snowy bank of a river
until the ice melted around me.
I trained with top athletes.
I crossed the finish line of the world's
most notorious cold weather
obstacle course race
wearing nothing but shorts and a smile.
I can do 80 pushups on a single breath,
and I lost seven pounds
of fat in seven days.
If I can do it, anyone can.
(guitar music)
I'm Scott Carney, and I'm
an investigative journalist,
and I'm here to climb Kilimanjaro
with Wim Hof, the madman.
We're going to do it in just two
days 'till we get to the top.
We're doing it because we can,
because this is the way to show
our bodies' physical potential
by unlocking some of what
evolution has given us
using very simple techniques,
breathing and cold exposure
and mental focus.
We feel like if we have all of that,
we're going to do something
really, really special.
So the normal ascent is
between five and eight days
to get to the summit of Kilimanjaro.
We're doing it in two.
When I asked the US
Army's environmental unit
what our success rate should be,
they said that we would have about
60 to 75 percent of the
people in this group
come down with acute mountain sickness.
They think that most of us are
not going to make it to the top,
and we're here to prove
that this technique
will let most of us get to the top,
hopefully all of us, and safely.
(suspenseful percussion music)
- This is awesome.
- Oh!
- Yeah, right up.
- Holy (audio cuts out)
- [Man] That is not easy, huh?
- It got cold in the valley.
(suspenseful percussion music)
(inspirational music)
- We have done it with
the Wim Hof himself,
with Salim.
Woo-hoo!
- Salim, our guide.
He set the pace.
He was amazing.
And we got Dennis here, the man
who looks better in a onesie
than I've ever seen in my life.
Look at this beautiful onesie.
- Wind and snow, man.
Cold wind and snow.
- Yeah, it's snowing.
Didn't go bare chested the
whole way, but you know what?
That doesn't matter.
We did it.
(inspirational music)
So I'm an investigative journalist,
and over the course of my career,
I have examined a lot of false gurus,
people who make really
advanced spiritual claims
and occasionally end with
people dying or getting hurt,
losing all their money,
that sort of thing.
And actually, the previous
book that I'd written,
A Death on Diamond Mountain,
explores not only my personal experience
with a friend of mine who died
on a meditation retreat in northern India,
but also the death of
a man named Ian Thorson
in the deserts of Arizona while studying
with a very controversial
Tibetan guru named Michael Roach.
And Roach made these claims
that he could give you
superpowers through meditation,
things like levitating,
things like walking through the walls,
things like telepathy, these things
which are in the yoga sutras
considered siddhis, or miracles.
Now, when I heard about Wim Hof,
I thought that he was going to be
another very sketchy
guru like Michael Roach,
'cause his claims were that
he could control his
body temperature at will,
consciously control his
autonomic nervous system
and his immune system,
which aren't quite as grandiose claims
as this other guy I looked
at, but potentially dangerous,
because what Wim Hof is famous for
is his incredible resilience.
(audio cutting out)
was the picture of him
sitting on an iceberg
somewhere north of the
Arctic Circle in just shorts,
shirtless in the cold, and
he looks sort of happy.
He has the record for an Arctic marathon,
again, barefoot in his shorts.
He's done marathons in the Sahara.
He's hiked two thirds up
the way Mount Everest,
also in his shorts.
And so I knew he had
some of these abilities,
he'd had a history with this.
However, what I worried was that
when he claims that he
can teach these things,
what might be his innate
biological abilities
are really the false claims
that could get someone killed.
So I had a assignment
from Playboy Magazine
to go there and write about his training.
And I got off the plane,
and initially, he's not
a very impressive person.
He's a Dutch fitness guru.
He's not incredibly tall.
He's got a big ruddy nose
from years of alcoholism.
He's a smoker.
He doesn't smell so great.
His speech is very disorganized.
And I was like, "Oh, this
guy is probably a sham."
So he meets me at the airport.
We're in Wroclaw.
This is the Polish winter.
I like to say it's the same winter
that stopped the Nazi army.
It's the same winter that
Napoleon turned his armies around.
And here I am.
I'm taking a cab with him into
the mountains of that area,
and he says basically
that in a couple days
I'll be standing out in
my shorts and a shirt
and heating myself up
consciously and have no trouble,
and I thought that was sort of crazy.
But, as an anthropologist, as
an investigative journalist,
as somebody who believes in the facts,
I can't just go there and say,
just write him off full stop
without giving him a chance.
So I say, "Okay, I'm going to
try your method for a few days,
"and the second that I start
feeling this is sketchy,
"that this is no good, I'm out."
And it turns out things were pretty cool.
You expose yourself to extreme-ish cold,
not like space temperatures,
but ice baths and things like that,
and then when you're in this stimulus
which would trigger your
fight or flight responses,
you suppress and redirect that response
to make it not happen.
So to give an example, in an ice bath,
you get into the ice bath
and instead of tensing up
and being like, "Oh my
god, this is horrible!"
you relax in that environment
and try to trigger
a different way to warm your
body through metabolic action
instead of the tension of your muscles.
And then he also has a
breathing method where,
basically, you hyperventilate
and hold your breath
and you hyperventilate
and hold your breath,
and what you're trying to do is
when you're holding your breath
is stretch out that point where
you feel the need to gasp.
And by doing that, you're also tweaking
that fight or flight response.
You're tweaking that feeling in your body
that seems autonomic, but
you're actually realizing
that there's some negotiation
that you have over that.
When you start the method,
it's this hyperventilation
and then there's the cold exposure.
And the first thing we did was
the hyperventilation routine.
And I knew beforehand that
I could hold my breath
for like 30 seconds or 45 seconds
if I just like (inhales
sharply) and held it.
That's how long I could last.
I did his method, and we're doing
this hyperventilation
stuff which looks like,
(gasping and huffing)
for like five or 10 or 15
minutes we're doing this.
And then I hold my breath
and I can hold my breath for two minutes,
and I thought that was pretty cool.
I didn't think it was a miracle,
but I thought it was pretty cool.
And then we kept on doing
that hyperventilation,
and then he said,
"Now, let all the air out of
your lungs and do pushups."
And I knew I could do 20 pushups.
I am not a extreme athlete or whatever,
especially at that point.
And I usually could do 20 pushups,
but here I am, with no air
in my lungs doing pushups,
and I put out 40 without breathing,
and I thought that was just so cool.
And that was probably the
moment where I'm like,
"Okay, I'm going to give this guy a shot
"to see what is actually happening."
And then, like you said, he said,
"Why don't we go stand out in the snow?"
And this is the winter of Poland,
so it's the winter that
stopped the Nazi army.
It's the winter that stopped Napoleon.
And it's like January.
And we stripped down
to nothing, basically.
I had a bathing suit on, that's it.
Stand in the snow.
And it freaking hurts.
Goddammit, I tell you,
it sucked 100 percent.
My feet, it's like they're on coals.
After five minutes, I run into a sauna,
and it hurts even more
when I'm in the sauna.
Warming up sucks even more.
And then I was like,
"Wim, you're an asshole,
"and I don't want to talk to you anymore,"
but he's like, "Yeah, yeah, I get that.
"That's always what happens
"the first time you expose yourself.
"Just see what happens tomorrow."
And the next day, I go
out, and I land 10 minutes
before that same feeling
of horror shows up.
And the day after that, it's 30 minutes,
and the day after that it's an hour,
and I'm sweating at an hour.
And I'm like, "Holy crap.
"This is big."
These are huge changes that
are happening really quickly,
and I was just living in
Los Angeles before this,
so that's like eternal summer.
And going from there
to this horrendously cold winter is crazy.
And at the end of all
of the Polish retreats,
you hike up this mountain called Snezka,
which is a ski slope, but it
had just snowed the day before.
And so we had like a foot of powder,
that much powder, on the ground.
And it took us eight
hours to get to the top,
and I was just in nothing, basically,
just shoes and shorts and a hat,
and I was sweating the whole way up.
And it just seemed so weird, right?
Who knew that my body had this power?
And it's not a miracle.
It's not like he shot prana energy at me--
(interviewers laughing)
The thing that's really cool was that
Wim's method is not a superpower.
It's just an ordinary human power
that we have left dormant
because we're all wimps
and we like being in this comfortable
72 degree temperature all the
time, having no variation,
and so what Wim is doing is just
putting variations into your daily routine
and then triggering what is essentially
evolutionary programming,
programming that we've had
that has allowed our species
to survive and get us to now.
He's just saying, "Here's how
to reactivate that stuff."
(inspirational music)
So Wim has done all of these crazy things.
He's able to sit in the ice
and control his body temperature,
and they put a rectal probe in him to show
that his body temperature rose in the ice
instead of declined.
And that was all very cool.
But then he made this claim
that he could consciously
turn off, or turn up,
his immune system at will,
which is at the point thought
physiologically impossible.
There's no mental connection
between the immune system and the brain.
But he said he could do it,
and so these immunologists
over at Radboud University,
in Nijmegen, there you go, got it,
named Dr. Peter Pickkers and Matthijs Kox,
what they did is devised a
test to see if he was right.
And the test originally exists
for testing cyclosporine and
other immunosuppressants,
which are used if you
get a kidney transplant.
Your body will usually reject the kidney
and it'll eat up the kidney,
and so what they need to do
is turn off your immune system
in order that you can
keep the kidney around.
So the way you test those drugs
is you give someone the drug
and then inject them with this
heat killed E. coli bacteria,
which is called endotoxin,
which in 99 percent of normal people
you get injected with it
and you get a fever, a runny nose.
You have all of the
primary immune responses
until your body figures out
that it has been tricked
and then it gives the big middle finger
and then it reverts to normal.
Now, Wim said that he could
do basically the same thing
as taking an immunosuppressant,
but with his mind.
- Which sounds super woo-woo.
If you know nothing about
this, this sounds so woo-woo
and saying you can control
your autonomic nervous system,
any doctor is going to
say, "That's impossible."
- The definition of autonomic means
you don't freaking control it.
It's automatic, right?
And actually, a lot of
stuff on this journey
ends up sounding woo-woo,
and I am allergic to a lot of it,
but you got to keep testing it,
and some of this works out.
So they inject him with endotoxin.
He was supposed to get a fever,
and he was like, "Oh, no, I feel fine.
"I just have a minor headache."
And that was all he said.
And then they were doing blood tests
and doing all these things.
And his blood actually
remained resistant to endotoxin
even after it was
extracted out of his body
and remained that way for
three days afterwards.
So it was shocking.
And there was this big
journal article that was like,
"Look at this (audio cuts out)"
And then some scientists saw this study,
and they're like, "Well, wait a minute.
"Wim is probably a genetic freak."
Remember, I said 99 percent of people
react in a predictable way,
but one percent are able to resist
or don't have that reaction.
So that's a totally fair
scientific assessment.
So what they did is a year later,
Pickkers and Kox gathered 12,
actually it was 18 volunteers,
six people in a control
group, 12 in an active group,
and they took those 12 guys
and they put them through
Wim's Poland training,
the same one that I did in Poland.
Actually, they were there the week after
I was reporting on the
Playboy story, same winter.
After that, they brought
them all back to Radboud
and injected them all with endotoxin,
and they repeated the same results.
Now, that journal article has been the one
that everyone is now looking at,
because what it proved is that
not only was Wim really interesting,
and look, he can suppress
his immune system,
but that he can teach it
and that it's generalizable.
And there's still ongoing
research, but that is the key,
because if you can suppress
your immune system,
then what does that mean
for autoimmune illnesses
like arthritis or lupus or Crohn's disease
where you have lesions from
your mouth to your butt,
and what the implications are?
And what I've seen personally
from interviews and meeting people is that
many folks are able to
reverse autoimmune illnesses
by doing stuff like the Wim Hof method,
this breathing, this conscious focus,
this ice baths and that sort of stuff.
And it's amazing.
This has potential impacts
for every autoimmune illness
out there in the world,
anything where your body
is attacking itself,
so think arthritis, think
lupus, think Crohn's disease.
To some degree, diabetes.
To some degree, Parkinson's.
All of a sudden, all of these people
are starting to use the Wim
Hof method to treat themselves
for a huge variety of
autoimmune illnesses.
And in the book, I look at
four case studies of four different people
who are using cold showers
and conscious breathing
to combat and reverse, in some cases,
Crohn's disease,
arthritis, and Parkinson's.
They're amazing anecdotes.
These are not totally randomized,
placebo controlled studies
that have gone on for 15 years.
But there are great bleeding edge results,
and they're real people
and I've seen them myself.
And I can say also in my own experience,
having done this breathing method
for about three, sorry, six years,
since a kid, I have always
been generally healthy
except for just one thing,
which is I've always gotten canker sores,
which are sort of like mouth ulcers.
And because I was exposed to
whatever the virus is that
starts it at a very young age,
I started getting them at one,
they could grow to be about
the size of a dime in my mouth,
which means, for me, they're
just incredibly painful,
difficult to talk, difficult to smile.
And I had tried everything in the world
to try to combat this.
I tried alternative medicines.
I tried Western medicines.
I did stupid things
like putting salt on it
'cause somebody told me that would work.
It was horrible.
- Painful.
- Since doing this method, I
haven't gotten them at all.
When I do the breathing,
when I do the cold,
these things don't surface,
and they used to surface
for me every two weeks.
So for me, that's been amazing.
Not quite as impressive as
Crohn's disease or arthritis,
but still very cool.
(inspirational music)
There's two really easy methods
to just start seeing
what your body can do,
which is take a shower, wash.
Easy so far, right?
Super easy.
Now, turn to the back of the shower
and do the hardest thing
you'll ever do in your life
and turn that knob to
cold, which really is hard.
(Scott mumbles)
(interviewer laughs)
This is really hard to
do, because you're like,
"I was warm, though."
And then sit in that cold, and then relax.
Just chill.
And it can be hard at first
because your response
could be very strong,
but you can do it, I promise you.
And relax there and just feel
that cold and then realize,
I know you've probably swam
in the ocean at some point,
and you realized when you
first got in it was cold
because you tiptoed in,
and then eventually you jumped in,
and then you swam around
and it was all right.
You're going to get to that same spot.
And do that.
Do that.
That's the entry point that
you can do every morning.
Do it first thing, and then
you'll get this great rush.
When you get out, you'll be like,
"Oh, everything is sort of easier today,
"and I feel like a glow."
That will totally happen.
Another thing that I
recommend to people is going,
if it's winter, going on a run outside
with just your skivvies on,
or if you're a woman, sports bra.
- Yeah. (laughs)
- And shoes.
And go for a run,
and just really just
not very much clothing,
and just realize that
the first minute or two
is going to be cold,
but then you're going to
build up some internal heat.
Or if you really want to be prepared,
you can do some pushups before you go out
so you've already built up some heat.
Go for a mile or two in
like 30 degree weather
or 20 degree weather
in a place where,
you can look at a frostbite
table if you want.
You can just google, "Frostbite
table," and you can see.
"Well, I can stay out for 30 minutes
"before frostbite might be a danger."
Okay, so do 29 minutes and
you're going to be all right.
And you're going to generate
so much heat anyway,
because when you run you generate
heat and you will be warm,
that you're going to
realize this is great.
And what's really cool,
what's happening is that your nerves,
even though you're
generating internal heat,
the nerves under your skin
are getting those messages saying,
"It's winter, and winter is coming,
"and therefore I'm going to
have to go get ready for this,"
and your body starts
to adapt super quickly,
and it's more or less painless to do.
And you know, I climbed
up to Mount Kilimanjaro.
I made it to Gilman's
Point, which is about 85,
sorry, 18,500 feet.
I was in a bathing suit
almost the whole way up.
You can, too.
It got down to negative 30 at times.
So use that as a guidepost of
where you might be able to,
I'm not saying Kilimanjaro
is what you need to do,
but that's a good start.
If you just do something like turn down
the thermostat in your house in the winter
to about 60 degrees, that will
give you some passive input,
and also cold showers.
This will do something.
This will tell your body,
you're giving signals to your
body to start doing things.
Now, if you want to do,
learn the Wim Hof breathing,
'cause it's really quite simple.
I do about 15 minutes a day of it.
You can do more.
You don't need to.
Read the book, and there's
this stuff to think about.
And remember, these are guidelines.
The headline here is that
the environment is important,
and the environment you inhabit
and your relation to it is important
and you should not take it for granted.
I think the breathing method
is absolutely critical to the method,
and I think it speeds it up.
I think it helps a lot.
And what it is it's this hyperventilation,
so it's like 30 or 40
deep, controlled breaths,
in which you're blowing
off CO2 out of your system
and you're increasing your O2
saturation up to 100 percent.
And then you hold your breath
with the air out of your lungs
and you try to get to that
point where you need to gasp,
where you feel like you're
like, "I got to breathe."
And by doing that, what you're doing is
interacting with an autonomic
system in your body,
which is where the gasp reflex is,
and you're telling your
body that you should have
some control over this one system.
And it's the same thing
that you do in a cold shower
when you're telling
yourself not to shiver.
It's the same skill of
becoming mentally strong
over an autonomic reflex.
And what this does,
and these two methods
works on different systems,
parasympathetic and sympathetic
systems in the body,
but what that does is give you
more resistance in the cold
and has this autonomic
trick, this autonomic ability
to influence your immune
system down the road,
which is incredibly useful.
So I wouldn't recommend,
if you're super lazy
and all you're going to do is
the cold shower, then great.
It's not going to be bad for you.
That's awesome.
That will help.
But really, the breathing
method only adds 12 minutes
to a morning workout.
I wake up in the morning.
I don't even get out of bed.
I just lie there next to my
wife, who's also doing this,
and we start with the breathing method,
which is 30 deep,
controlled, rapid breaths
that would look something like this.
It would go ...
(gasping and huffing)
Like a little stop at the top and you go,
and you do about 30 of those.
You'll get lightheaded, maybe
you'll have tingly fingers,
something like that.
And then at the end of it,
you let all the air out,
(exhales sharply) and hold it.
And I usually will have
a stopwatch with me.
On my iPhone, there's one.
And then I hold it for
about a minute like that,
and then I repeat.
I do 30 breaths, and then air out,
and I do a stopwatch and
I do it for two minutes,
I hold my breathe for two
minutes, and the third time,
I'll do the same rep but I'll
hold it for three minutes.
And people will have different times.
Don't worry too much about the times.
Just be sure that you're
improving with every one,
and that's usually not an issue.
And then I'll do one
more rep of breathing,
and I'll get out of my bed and
I'll do breath out pushups,
so all the air out of my lungs
and I just start doing pushups,
and I do 50 every morning.
And I end up with, I
don't know why I do this,
but I do a headstand at the end of it,
and then I give my wife a hug,
and then I'm ready to go eat breakfast.
And I want to tell you that it
snowed in Denver last night,
which means we got about a foot of snow,
and according to the city, we
have to go shovel our walkway,
so I wanted to give you
a quick winter workout
that really anyone can
do, and it's a lot of fun.
At the moment, it's about two
degrees Fahrenheit in Denver.
Let's go.
(rapid piano music)
All right.
That was a lot of fun.
I hope you enjoy your winter.
I know I will.
And if you need a little bit more cold
'cause you worked up a little
bit, there's always the snow.
Pretty easy, and it feels great.
Ah.
(sighs)
(laughs)
(techno music)
(inspirational music)
- So thank you guys so much for watching.
I'd love to know, what did
you think of this video?
What do you think of the Wim Hof method?
Have you tried it?
I have definitely noticed
an improvement in my health
since getting started, so I'm
extremely grateful for that.
Let me know in the comments below.
Also, if you want to check out
the first Wim Hof video that
we made, go check that out.
I think you'll learn a lot from it.
And you could check out Scott's
book, What Doesn't Kill Us,
wherever you pick up books.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love.
I'll see you soon.
(loud whoosh)
(bang)